I know this is a totally innocent comment
and there's literally nothing against commenter
however I don't like it when we talk about issues with like
romantic love and the automatic response is oh
you have to love yourself
like self love is not going to replace romantic love
it's not gonna replace the desire for that and
you know the feelings that come with it
so um
I would just like
I don't know I I
I think a lot of people are struggling with dating and romance
and having a crush
like I think it's a very normal thing to do
and I don't think that you have to just like
learn to love yourself because I
I do love myself
that doesn't help with me being insane when I have a crush